bien des difficiles oui pourquoi faire
simple quand on peut faire compliqué et
pourquoi faire compliqué quand on peut
faire simple c'est aussi l'une des idées
maîtresses que vous avez au moment du
lancement d'europe numéro un au
lancement d'europe numéro un j'ai
d'abord réagi en auditeurs et c'est vrai
que la radio que j'entendais ne me
donnait pas tout à fait satisfaction
alors on va retrouver quelques quelques
figures de repeindre sont âgés de 20 ans
ils ont demandé le droit d'asile aux
autorités autrichiennes histoire et
tchad
peut-être que quelqu'un en contre un
dirigeant de lait des aides pour savoir
si dans un plant coupure précis et qui
pourront voir vous ne pas avoir recruté
pas écouter les les péripéties lunaire
demain matin encore quantité de gens qui
ont des récepteurs radio non transit
stories et qui se trouve juste de
brancher sur sur du courant et si on
veut écouter en direct ce qui se passe à
7 heures demain matin est admettre
qu'ils vont pouvoir se sent 84 boulevard
saint-michel 35-29 chez renault
déjeuner chaud mademoiselle un événement
politique non non mais une question
monsieur là mademoiselle
lb ce moment qu'est ce que je fais je
fais le sud ouest et l'ouest maintenant
et puis je fais pas oublier le pas la
pluie et même un paravent si possible
notre faveur dit qu on m étais je